it's not happening again
[Applause]
come on now
hey hey
i want it i want it even louder
i want to not be able to even hear my
own thoughts
all right zuma's here i want him to have
to plug his ears okay all right let's go
[Music]
oh it's gonna be perfect
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i got to reload i got to reload
i need to breathe i need to breathe
there's a lot of pressure on me right
now
there we go
[Music]
one more
bye
[Music]
come on now
[Music]
what is this
oh oh hell no oh no no no no no i'm good
i'm good i'm good i'm good
[Music]
this guy's a tank
[Music]
[Music]
excuse me
sure
well
we should be safe from now
hey look uh
by the way you see this jacket i'm
wearing
if you're watching out there right now
you can win this jacket which
technically i don't know i'm allowed to
say has the brand new warzone full map
stitched on the inside
uh tweet hashtag vanguard
sweepstakes for a chance to win okay
let's get back in
hey joey joey
you guys sound great can we just quiet
that i want to hear that you want to
hear it all yeah yeah sorry you guys are
doing great but this is kind of why i'm
here
let's try to get closer
[Music]
this is bad for nina
she's
[Music]
get down
[Music]
yes
i got
you let's go
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
i have you
[Music]
the ridiculous music when i get killed
that's what we have to do that's that's
the way it goes
all right
we also no one told me someone had a
bayonet on this level so
i'm carrying a half dead guy and i have
a pistol
[Music]
steady over
[Music]
[Music]
i have you
come on now
bye
[Music]
[ __ ]
hold on to me
stay with me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that that's gotta hurt
[Music]
[Applause]
you're delirious
come on we have to move on
you cover the opening i go out and flank
them
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it uh it wouldn't be a call of
duty stream if we didn't have
f's in the chat right now
for whoever's watching online you know
you know
[Music]
all right
keep on your toes you know
you guys are the ones providing the
music
[Music]
all right i'm sorry
[Music]
sheesh
steiner
[Music]
[Music]
hey joey how about every time i take
someone down can you give me like an
inception like
as loud as you can please
it's the best movie of all time so
way better than interstellar
i don't understand what you're saying
all right right now
[Music]
okay
okay hold on here
three two one
man
that is satisfying you have more for me
wait we can we can do this all night oh
yeah i'll fight you right now joey
you get a box to stand on to be taller
okay i'm still five nine
six three
oh you know what
[Music]
all right all right
boy susan
[Music]
how athletic is she oh my god
oh no
okay
hmm
[Music]
[Music]